l'ambiance qui étaient plutôt bonnes du
côté de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet après midi
laurence cousin donc je ne sais pas si à
versailles l'ambiance est la même au
bureau 10000 information jeunesse mais
vous pouvez prendre exemple
trop réfléchir elle aime chez rick
pourquoi pas classe carreaux
effectivement on va parler de vos
actualités elles sont toujours
nombreuses alors je rappelle que céline
information jeunesse est une structure
nationale qui fonctionne en réseau 27
centres régionaux études projets
professionnels initiative droit santé
logement vous renseigner avec vos
équipes lé sujet sur tous les sujets qui
concernent directement les jeunes demain
27 mars 10h à 12h30 à vous informer sur
les formations professionnelles en
alternance comment va se dérouler ce
rendez vous eh bien écoutez c'est un
partenariat qu'on a mis en place avec la
chambre de commerce déjà puis depuis
déjà plus de cinq ans
l'idée c'est vrai que les jeunes sont
souvent intéressés par des formations en
alternance mais que ça à demande une
méthodologie qui ne maîtrisent pas
toujours ce qui est tout à fait normal
d'ailleurs et là l'idée c'est de faire
intervenir donc le siècle le centre
d'information et d'orientation
professionnelle pour vraiment les
accompagner au cas par cas selon leurs
besoins donc ça va vraiment de déjà bien
sûr qui dit formation professionnelle
dit valider son projet professionnel
c'est vraiment le le démarrage et puis
ensuite maîtrisé bas cv lettre de
motivation conseils pour l'entretien
d'embauché connaître le contrat de
travail que l'on doit signer pour
intégrer ses phares enfin toutes ces
démarches là on les laisse pas seuls et
on les accompagne au fil des ateliers
alors y aura plusieurs filières qui
seront forcément mises en avant il ya
une nouveauté aussi c'est le crp petite
enfance une formation on peut peut-être
108 ans tout à fait parce qu'en fait
pour la première fois donc là on a mis à
donc
le lycée saint vincent de paul de
versailles donc va participer à nos
ateliers
l'idée c'est de recruter effectivement
et notamment sur leur nouvelle formation
le srp petite enfance qui vont proposer
en un an en alternance c'est ce que
l'alternance aujourd'hui à meilleure
presse pendant un temps c'est un petit
peu le parent pauvre de l'éducation les
parents justement de souhaiter
séparément et inscrire leur enfant
préféré les formations plus
traditionnels classiques les études
longues aujourd'hui ça a changé oui ça
change et malheurs après la difficulté
c'est que finalement ça a basculé c'est
que la crise est passée par là et que
les entreprises et bien du mal à
recruter même en alternance donc les
jeunes sont obligés de se vendre comme
pour une recherche d'emploi classique il
ya moins de place c'est parce qu'ils
sont ils voient la ramade emploi
classique il faut postuler il faut avoir
un cv il faut se rendre tout à fait donc
c'est ce qu'on essaie de le rapporter
via ces ateliers les différentes dates
qu'on propose en 2013 pour autant on a
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup d'écoles
aussi qu'ils forment à l'alternance
beaucoup d'écoles ça veut pas dire
beaucoup d'entreprises vous nous l'avez
rappelé voilà ça veut dire qu'il faut
faire le bon choix aussi lorsqu'on est
étudiant il faut non seulement se vendre
près d'une entreprise et puissent
choisir aussi la bonne école l'école qui
va tenir et qui va apporter la bonne
formation laisser fab de toute façon au
niveau si on veut passer un diplôme il
ya un référentiel sur les diplômes donc
en termes de formation les cfa
après ça dépendra effectivement de la
compagnon qui vont apporter aux jeunes
est-ce qu'il prospecte pour justement
avoir un vivier d'entreprises à
disposition toutes les écoles toutes les
formations ne se valent pas forcément
vous êtes aussi la pourrir voilà moi
vraiment le l'objectif principal déjà
c'est la validation du projet
professionnel parce que ça je pense
qu'il faut vraiment mettre l'accent
dessus et sur le calendrier parce que
effectivement en juillet c'est pas qu'il
est trop tard mais c'est très compliqué
avec les vacances d'été qui a qui
approche de trouver un employeur sur le
sur l'été sur la période juillet-août
taxées dès demain qu'il faut sans doute
arrivée pourrait vous rendre à
versailles une information vraie entrée
libre à son inscription donc telles sont
les questions peut-être qui reviennent
le plus souvent parce que vous organisez
souvent ce genre de réunion les jeunes
viennent le plus souvent avec quel type
de questions ils savent déjà le projet
professionnel qu'ils veulent développer
où ils sont vraiment au point zéro tout
début et bien ça dépend c'est vrai qu'on
a différents profils en fait c'est vrai
qu'il n'ya pas un jeune en particulier
mais vraiment comme je disais c'est
vraiment au cas par cas mais souvent ils
arrivent avec lydia peu préconçue de
dire il me faut un employeur est en fait
à nous on fait de leur poser des
questions et de voir s'ils ont déjà
acquis tous les éléments en amont pour
avoir les meilleures chances de trouver
l'employeur l'autre actualité divine
information jeunesse c'est le forum le
10 avril après-midi mot d'ordre l'europe
c'est possible aussi bien pour étudier
que pour décrocher un boulot d'été
d'ailleurs on va détailler votre
programme mais déjà est-ce que
l'étranger fait peur est ce que l'europe
fait peur parce que les jeunes partent
facilement ah oui je pense que la
mobilité européenne
je pense que tous les jeunes sont
conscients que c'est une vraie valeur
ajoutée sur un cv une expérience à
l'étranger que ce soit pour un job un
stage
c'est quand même un vrai plus après
c'est le financement donc nous on est là
puisque donc ma collègue qui s'en occupe
on est labellisé europe direct donc on a
vraiment des informations qui sont
fiables
l'idée c'est de pouvoir déjà les
informations d informer sur les
dispositifs qui existent et sur les
accompagnements qui existent aussi elle
savait mentionné ce label il une
information jeunesse qui a reçu ce label
europe direct il a été renouvelé oui 50
structures dont cinq en ile-de-france un
label qui signifie corée eh bien ça veut
dire qu'en fait il ya un dossier il ya
vraiment un cahier des charges on va
dire
à remplir donc c'est vraiment un gage de
qualité
sachant qu en île de france par exemple
et vous avez donc ça que la belle qui
ont été renouvelés donc nous en ligne
d'information jeunesse également nos
collègues du cij du val d'oise le 6 juin
77 la messe la maison de l'europe du 78
et le dis là donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
finalement peu de peu de structures et
là vraiment le gâche c'est d'avoir des
supports d'information une qualité de
l'information gratuite et aussi de cette
information et l'information que vous
allez délivré le 10 avril pour ceux qui
veulent décrocher un petit boulot à
l'étranger aussi quelles sont les
structures qui proposent des emplois à
l'étranger si on veut trouver un boulot
quand on est étudiant pour l'été alors
nous l'idée c'est de pouvoir leur
proposer un panel qui leur permet de
trouver une solution par rapport à l'or
à leur situation et leurs priorités ça
peut passer du clé en main par un parent
un séjour linguistique vous pouvez avoir
des stages des jobs mais là c'est un
coup après si le jeune est autonome il
peut effectivement notamment via des
sites internet trouver des sources et
des offres de jobs a trouvé aussi
peut-être des logements parce que si on
veut aller faire un petit boulot à
l'étranger pendant l'été faux
sismologiques bien entendu donc nous
notre basse et les fiches actuelle cdj 1
où on a des fiches pays qui justement
développer différents axes dont ont
besoin les jeunes à savoir je vais
étudier je veux faire un stage veut
travailler je veux me loger dans le pays
en question quelles sont les pistes en
france et à l'étranger on parle donc de
ces jobs d'été notamment à l'étranger
puisque c'est un petit peu le thème de
la réunion voilà des points qui sera le
tabac oui voilà parce que certains
voient là puisqu'on un focus aussi sur
les jobs de proximité on un site
internet du boston qui nous permet tout
au long de l'année d'avoir des offres de
jobs pour les jeunes donc pour l'été ou
sur notre période et puis on va aussi
inviter des partenaires donc le 10 avril
de 14 heures à 18 heures pour que les
jeunes soient confrontés directement
recruteurs et puissent déposer leur cv
et puis on annonce il y aura la mission
locale le pôle emploi il ya aussi un
accompagnement notamment pour ceux qui
n'ont pas forcément un cv ou la
démotivation
nickel s'ils veulent des conseils et un
regard de professionnel on sera là pour
ça et puisqu'on parlait de ces jobs à
l'étranger nous sommes allés poser cette
question dans les rues de saint quentin
en yvelines aujourd'hui notre question
du jour que pensez vous de l'idée d'un
job d'été à l'étranger êtes vous plutôt
partant ouais les jobs d'été c'est
intéressant ça permet de développer des
capacités linguistiques à l'étranger
surtout nous comme on étudiants pas de
nous faire un peu d'argent quoi financer
l'année tout ça bah oui ça peut être
intéressant à visiter à l'étranger si ça
peut permettre déjà
de d'enrichir sa propre culture
peut-être si c'est un pays anglophone
mieux parler anglais ça permet de
voyager en même temps de se faire
d'argent donc c'est pas mal quoi je vois
c'est une très bonne opportunité non
seulement d'apprendre la langue de se
débrouiller un peu plus par ce même en
quittant le cadre familial ou des amis
et de bacilles aventure quam étrangers
ça peut aussi être valorisant de
l'intégrer dans un cv plus tard si on
veut travailler en relation avec
l'international est l'un des meilleurs
moyens de gagner de l'argent pour moi
enfin en même temps on gagne de l'argent
et en plus on fait un voyage donc c'est
tout bénef c'est tout bénef étudiait
faire un job à l'étranger pendant l'été
c'est tout bénéf et voilà bien résumé et
pour ça encore il faut savoir se vendre
une fois de plus vous faites des cv vous
aider à rédiger ce sont donc là on va
faire appel à une bénévole qui bat qui
vend fait pratiquer une structure depuis
de nombreuses années et qui est bien
anglais et qui va donc se proposer pour
aider les jeunes qui le souhaitent à
élaborer leur cv leur lait de motivation
en anglais et en espagnol en ce moment
se déroule à un salon sur paris un salon
justement qui lance un petit peu cette
saison pour les jobs d'été et qui permet
aux étudiants aux jeunes de trouver un
salon spécialisé et le constat dans la
presse c'était tout simplement que la
concurrence était très rude cette année
avec les chômeurs forcément le chômage
qui explose on attend encore de très
mauvais chiffres aujourd'hui 1 26 mars
pour les derniers chiffres concernant le
chômage au niveau national et aussi dans
le département des yvelines l'occasion
d'en parler ça veut dire que les jeunes
qui viennent vous voir aujourd'hui il
faut aussi leur apprendre à être en
concurrence avec eux des salariés qui
recherchent un nouveau travail et oui
tout à fait c'est vrai que depuis
quelques années on peut constater que
certaines personnes qui sont en
difficulté nous demanderait ce que je
peux venir sur un forum jobs d'été bon
si ce sont des seniors alors après il ya
un mélange de genres effectivement mais
qu'on peut qu'on peut comprendre mais
qui n'est pas forcément adapté c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a appelée notre
job en stock on insiste sur le mot jobs
inquiétez pas les objectifs sont pas
forcément les mêmes il arrive
quelquefois que certains même s'ils ne
répondent pas aux critères de de la
jeunesse pour répondre petits plats ce
que vous proposez viennent vous voir
pour vous demandez vous n'avez pas un
emploi et oui parce qu'en fait c'est
accessible à tous donc on peut pas
fermer si vous voulez la diffusion des
offres après on les aime un petit peu en
garde sur la pertinence en fait d'une
présence d'une autre site pour quelqu'un
qui cherche un emploi à temps plein cd
key qui recherchent à qui a une
formation professionnelle voyez c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose c'est
révélateur effectivement d'un contexte
social plutôt plutôt compliqué juste
pour pour conclure on peut peut-être
révoquer le guide destiné aux jeunes que
vous venez de dire est que de votre
structure des appareils à vide qui
existe depuis cinq ans qui est
plébiscité qui donne pleins
d'informations notamment études
insertion tout ce qui est initiative
jeune vie pratique il vient juste de
sortir en mars donc il est vous pouvez
vous procurer gratuitement dans le
réseau information jeunesse et
éventuellement le télécharger sur notre
site c'est là qu'il va s'afficher voilà
qui va s'afficher gratifie 78 points en
guerre merci elle remercie de dates à
retenir permanence alternance 27 mars
10h 12h et puis forum études emploi à
l'étranger 1 10 avril à 14 heures à 18
heures à versailles dans vos locaux
merci à vous nous continuons à évoquer
l'actualité locale dans le 7 8 avec à
saint-cyr-l'ecole à la concertation
autour de l'aménagement de la zac
charles renard qui s'engagent dans
quelques années sortiront de terre
plusieurs milliers de logement et des
équipements publics les habitants sont
donc invités à faire part de leurs
réflexions et puis rester avec nous
juste après à la chronique de
l'environnement avec julie rocha soirée
et des conseils pour bien jardiner
une ville dans la ville à saint cyr
l'école sur l'ancienne emprise de la
caserne de renard un projet de zone
d'aménagement sur 25 hectares dans
quelques années sortiront de terre 1500
logements un complexe sportif une maison
des associations et des jeunes un groupe
scolaire de 16 classes et des commerces
naissains syriens sont invités à
participer depuis ce samedi à des
ateliers de réflexion et je n'ai
trousses habite la résidence en face de
la caserne j'habite ton première l'enjeu
pourquoi pas oui
l'inquiétude c'est au niveau de la
circulation au niveau maintenant
bon j'ai caché à la retraite donc j'ai
pu d'enfants à garder c'est vrai qu'il
va y avoir des comptes des grands
complexes je pense sportif
crèches etc
circulation espaces verts équipements
publics d'éducation tout ou presque est
passé en revue c'est toujours
intéressant de l'écouté de voir s'il ya
des choses que l'on peut encore corriger
apporter une contribution par exemple
sur des attentes ou qui vont avoir pour
des aires de jeux pour les enfants la
façon dont on circule dans ce dans ce
quartier au niveau de ce qu'on appelle
les modes douce donc on a eu tout un tas
de remarques ce matin puis qui vont se
poursuivre cet après midi lors du
prochain atelier qui nous pour nous
permettre de défi de finaliser le
programme et prendre en compte ces
attentes
une trentaine de personnes pour ces
premiers ateliers le prochain aura lieu
le 13 avril et concernera les plans de
circulation et des accès un domaine où
les habitants auront forcément des
choses à dire